hi everyone thanks for coming
as alex mentioned my name is lara acken
and i'm an assistant professor
of social psychology at simon fraser
university
but i'm also a wife a mom to an
extremely handsome english bulldog
and a big sister to this big fella my
baby brother josh
now years ago when josh and i were
little we used to spend a lot of time
playing games
together and while i like to think that
i was a kind big sister
i have a striking memory of a nasty game
i used to play on my brother
back when he was less of a physically
threatening force
and this game wasn't so much a game as
it was a trick which involved me telling
josh
that nickels were worth more than dimes
because coins were valued based on their
size
and now to make my case i pointed
towards consistent and familiar evidence
for instance i reminded josh that
loonies are bigger than quarters
and also worth more josh agreed
similarly i reminded him that quarters
are bigger than nickels and also worth
more
josh agreed so then i went on to tell
him that it followed obviously that
because nickels were bigger than dimes
they were also worth more luckily for me
josh agreed
so i traded him handfuls of nickels for
dimes
essentially doubling my worth which was
probably four dollars at the time
and marched straight down the street to
the corner store to buy bags of penny
candy
because i thought that would make me
happy now
why do i tell you the story well it's
not to illustrate that i'm a bad person
or a terrible big sister but to
illustrate there are times when we as
human beings act in selfish ways
to further our own self-interest here i
lied to my baby brother to earn extra
cash
because i wanted to buy myself something
that i thought would make me happy
i acted in accordance with what some
might call my selfish genes and try to
improve my stake
at the cost at some of someone else but
does this childish tale of trickery
deceit and sugar sum up our human
existence
well i would argue that no it doesn't so
every day we can look around the world
around us and see kind acts both large
and small
so for instance an extreme example might
be the actions of ken
taylor the canadian ambassador to iran
who sheltered six us diplomats
during the hostile takeover and
revolution in 1980
and while taylor's actions are extremely
heroic we can see smaller scale acts
every day
from the surprise bouquet of flowers we
get from our friends and our or our
spouse
to the free cup of coffee left for us at
a local tim hortons which i did not
receive today but i
haven't purchased a coffee so maybe
that's why
um anyway point is the point is is that
small acts of giving in kindness are
indeed all around us
and in my brief time with you today i'd
like to argue that these acts of
kindness are not just good for the
recipient as we might suspect
but that helping others can actually
increase our own well-being
so i started off studying this question
during my graduate studies while working
with elizabeth dunn and mike norton
trying to investigate how people can
kind of gain the most happiness from
their everyday spending choices
and to starting off investigating this
question
liz mike and myself conducted a large
nationally representative survey
of over 600 americans and we asked them
to tell us
two separate pieces of information first
we asked for information about how
much they spend in an average month on
four spending categories
so the first was their expenses rent
bills and debt
the second was gifts for themselves the
third was gifts for others
and the fourth was donations to charity
we also asked people to tell us how
happy they were
on a one item happiness scale now to get
an idea of how much money people spent
on themselves and others in an average
month
we sum together these four spending
categories into two spending indices
so what i mean by that is we created an
index of what i'll call
personal spending by summing together
how much money people spent on
expenses rent bills and debt along with
gifts for themselves
telling how much went to themselves and
similarly we created an index of what
i'll call
pro-social spending which is how much
money people put in an
average month towards others so for
donations to charity or gifts to other
people
then we simply asked how do these two
spending indices relate to people's
well-being
well we did some pretty simple
statistics and came up with some pretty
striking results
what we found was first and foremost how
much money people spent on themselves in
an
average month was pretty much unrelated
to their own well-being
so pouring tons of money into gifts for
yourself for your own everyday expenses
didn't seem to really pay off in terms
of happiness
interestingly however how much money
people spend on
others did indeed predict their
happiness such that spending more on
others was associated with higher levels
of happiness
and i should note that this was true
across the income spectrum so this
suggests that how much money we spend on
others
might be associated with higher levels
of happiness
but to find out whether giving or
spending on others actually causes
higher levels of happiness
we followed up with an experiment in
which i went out in the morning hours on
campus
recruited a bunch of students and gave
them an envelope with either a five or
twenty dollar bill
that they were told they had to spend
that day now half of the students were
told to put this money towards something
for themselves
so they were told to cover a bill
expense or go out and buy themselves a
gift
the other half were told that they had
to use this money for someone else
so they had to put it towards a gift for
someone else or a donation to charity
now importantly everybody was told to
spend the money by five o'clock
so that a research assistant could call
them in the evening and find out how
they were feeling
so what did we find well we found that
people who were randomly assigned to
spend money on others were significantly
happier at the end of the day
here it was regardless of whether they
were spending five or twenty dollars
those who spent on others were happier
now an important question i think we can
raise from this is whether these
findings i've reported so far
something that might be unique to north
america where
a number of people might report having
extra disposable income
that they can choose to spend on others
but what happens if we go to other
countries and cultures around the world
where people might have less money to
spend and might presumably get the most
benefit from spending on themselves
well to address this question i
partnered with an international
collaborative team and a fantastic
economist who you'll hear from later
john and we went to countries to we went
to we collected a sample
of data from canada a relatively rich
nation
but also from a relatively uh poor
sample in south africa
and all these participants came into the
lab they were asked to fill out some
questionnaires and they were told that
in exchange for the time
they had earned an additional study
payment that they could use to buy
a goodie bag filled with treats like
chocolate or juice
now half of the students were told that
these goodie bags would be for them and
available for pickup at the conclusion
of the experiment
but the other half were told that their
goodie bag would be donated to a
sick kid at a local children's hospital
now
everybody had the option to opt in or
opt out of purchasing this goodie bag
but almost everybody decided to purchase
it
and then we asked them how are you
feeling afterward well what we found was
the same as what we had seen in north
america before
people who were randomly assigned to use
their money to purchase a goodie bag for
someone else
were happier than those who were
assigned to buy the same goodie bag for
themselves
now this is true even though
participants who were giving the goodie
bag away essentially
had no contact with their recipient and
importantly this was true
both in canada where a large proportion
of our students reported that they had
extra disposable income
but also in south africa where a
sizeable proportion of our sample
reported difficulty securing food for
themselves and their family in the past
12 months
so looking beyond canada and south
africa we were able to analyze data from
over 230 000 participants in 136
countries
by looking at data from the gallup world
poll and what we did was ask a simple
and similar question which
is whether donating money to charity in
the last
12 in the last month is associated with
higher levels of happiness
what we found was similar to what we had
seen before
such that in 88 of the country surveyed
we found a positive relationship between
donating money to charity and happiness
now these findings can actually be seen
in this world map here
where countries shown in green indicate
a positive relationship
between donating money to charity and
happiness while countries shown in red
indicate a negative relationship
the darker the color the stronger the
relationship and as you can see
the world is mainly green suggesting a
pervasive link between giving and
happiness
around the world all right so by now
i've hopefully started to convince you
that giving to others has
measurable and observable benefits for
our own well-being
but at what age do we as human beings
start to find giving rewarding
well there's some new research emerging
that indicating that young kids like to
engage
or sorry begin engaging in sharing
behavior and helpful behavior
spontaneously and they start to do so
quite early in life as early as 18
months young kids are offering to help
other people
and in fact sometimes they'll do it when
it involves some active self-sacrifice
such as
getting up and walking away from a fun
game to go help someone in need
now why are young kids engaging in this
potentially costly helping behavior
well i'd like to argue that just like
the adults i've been talking about so
far
young kids might also feel good about
giving
so to test this question i partnered
with a developmental psychologist
kylie hamlin and elizabeth dunn another
social psychologist to explore this
question
and what we did was we recruited a
sample of 20 toddlers just under the age
of two
and we asked them to come into the lab
with a parent or a caregiver
and they receded across the table from
an experimenter who
introduced them to a puppet named monkey
who was a monkey
and they were told that monkey liked
eating treats
then each child was given their own
little plastic bowl
and eight edible treats stuff that kids
really like like goldfish crackers or
teddy graham crackers
then over the next few minutes each kid
was taken through a series of giving
ex giving stages if you will first they
were asked to watch is the experimenter
gave a treat to monkey
then they were asked to give one of the
experimenters treats to monkey
and finally they were asked to give one
of their own treats to monkey
now every time monkey received a treat
he ate it in a large and very showy way
so he leaned forward shoved his face in
the bowl and went
and appeared to eat the treat now
obviously you as adults know that a
stuffed animal monkey can't consume a
treat
but we convinced the kids that he could
by pushing the treat through a false
bottom corner in the bowl making it
disappear
making it look as if monkey had actually
eaten the tree
and we wanted to know how the kids
responded to these different giving and
receiving opportunities
so we captured their expressions on
videotape and later coded their faces
for how much
how much happiness was present or to
what extent they were smiling
we of course were interested in whether
kids were happier giving treats away
that they were when receiving treats
and whether the emotional benefits of
giving might differ on account of
whether they were giving their own food
or food that kind of belonged to the
experimenter so what did we find
well first and foremost we found that
kids did smile more
when giving treats away to others than
they did when receiving treats
themselves
and this was true both when they gave a
treat that belonged to the experimenter
or when they gave an identical treat
from their own stash
but what's even more exciting is that
kids smiled
much larger or showed more happiness if
you will when they gave away their own
treat than when they gave away the same
identical treat
that belonged to the experimenter so
this might suggest that giving is
actually especially rewarding
when it involves some act of
self-sacrifice
all right so um the simple take-home
message i'd like to leave you with today
is that giving to others can actually
promote our own well-being
but before i say goodbye or before i
conclude i'd just like to address the
very real possibility that some of you
are sitting here thinking
well that's all well and good but i kind
of had an intuition about this to begin
with
i may have not had slides or a
powerpoint available to make my case
but i've been thinking about this too
and well to that i say kudos
good for you but it turns out we've
asked a large sample of over a hundred
adults
to tell us their predictions on the
matter and when we do so we find that
the significant majority seem to think
that they'll get larger emotional
rewards
from spending on themselves than from
than on others
now in a weird way this makes me feel a
little bit better because it suggests my
eight-year-old self wasn't some
deviant who thought that stealing money
from her brother
to buy candy for herself would make her
happier i wasn't alone is the point i
was saying
most adults seem to hold a similar
intuition that spending money on
themselves will make them happier
however what i think is better news is
that
armed with a little bit of knowledge we
can correct these intuitions
so little me is all grown up and i've
learned my lesson
and now i know that if what if happiness
is really what i'm after
rather than steal my brother's money to
buy myself candy
it would be oh so much sweeter to give
him some so that's exactly what i've
done
thank you
you